this is super watermelon Island and gem
drill we're back and we got talking
bubbles uh bubble up in this shit kind
of my accident we saw these two
back-to-back because they're running on
Cartoon Network now than on Amazon so we
have to just sort of find them by any
means necessary and the way that we
found
I just you've become perfect the way I
actually we didn't fire it and um it was
Cartoon Network
they had them but they put them back to
back and I was very confused because
like about 18 minutes ago I guess how is
Episode II really long yeah and we look
and it's like both these episode so it's
like okay and they like cut out the you
know the credits in the middle so it's
just like okay um so we'll just talk
about back-to-back uh you got this
watermelon Island which is particularly
fine cuz Rob completely forgot about the
watermelon episode so he's just watch
was like what is this like I thought you
saw it I thought like that was other
wanna said okay sure somebody's gonna
look it up and me like yeah he saw it
are now he didn't but if there was like
about maybe four episodes that you did
without me and I'm wondering if it was
one of those cuz I better I've gone
insane cuz I have no fucking memory of
that what's it I'm like racking my brain
I'm like I do not remember a Stephen
watermelon and I feel like Isaac Watts I
feel like of all things I'd remember I
actually make zombie he makes all these
Stephen watermelon it was kind of a blow
off episode it's like oh isn't that
funny but they they all go to this
island and Stephen has this ability to
go to sleep and wake up in one of them a
I feels like a lost dommage in the
beginning there uh and I just like super
watermelon Island it sounds like a mario
world yes like now warp to super
watermelon Island level six they do
bring out the n64 controller later so
maybe um and uh I guess they just
sacrifice some of them to the the
malachite creature comes out of the
water I guess yeah under these Stevens
at Shikha
um which yeah you say we need to save
them it's like I don't know they seem
pretty messed up but but okay whatevs
you know they're like you watch they
look all cute but really deep down there
you motherfuckers yeah they won't eat
you oh so uh so yeah so the gems go try
stop malachite which as you were saying
it's like I'm glad other people are
getting use out of that name not just
does um and they and Steven goes to
sleep wakes up in a watermelon and gets
the other watermelon you know and I'm
safe like that you're making it sound
weird yeah just a bit well when you sum
it up it's like this sounds kind of
crazy um so the watermelons fight the
giant fused hybrid and the hybrid fight
the other hybrids and um yeah some of
the watermelons wear ties and clothes
others don't
I'm Kal wondering what if it's like a
new disc allottee or not it's a it's
like most cartoons some wear ties and in
clothes and others don't and some wear
white gloves as well stir bunny never
had any pan that's shoe and yeah half of
a Babs had a skirt go figure
Oh his junks just line up that ruins it
but out there Babs got a cover-up for
some and again um but uh yeah and they
they separate malachite they fall apart
but they lose was it the orange one goes
down the crater but they saved the blue
one and and by the way the wanton
watermelon death good what the what an
IP on a guide I feel like a million
melons cried out in vain and were
suddenly silenced and then in the second
episode um peridot and him get the drill
they start going down and they find the
cluster and that's even zamacois Lester
phobic duh cluster phobic cluster 4 ha
ha ha
it was terrible
wonderful no it you laughed really hard
fellows awesome sorry lag action he left
sarcastically um so they go down Stephen
doesn't want harm this thing cuz it
feels like it's just all these
consciousnesses and they just don't know
what to do they don't wanna hurt my
mother grow going to anyway so do you
think thinks how we're all born like
this is like a little zygote or whatever
you like Moss grow must grow in general
I kind of like it I'm like there is
something so primitive about that just
likes just that how life works must grow
don't care who we killing away must grow
yeah like is like a muse of evolution so
as life finds a way yes even plants are
kind of like that actually at me it's
like they don't care what they'll kill
they'll just grow over anything destroy
whatever you like my neighbors wouldn't
kill me I would just let the weeds grow
good but I guess fucking come back just
like I consume the house um but Steven
finds a way to bubble them and then they
find a way to bubble themselves and it's
all one big bubblicious party yes
they got me your eyes back and everybody
seems to be happy so um I guess we'll do
them individually the I don't we just
did it no no like talk about what we
thought of them now um the first one I
thought the watermelon Island you know I
like everything except the watermelons
thank you oh my god like my bro there's
like this awesome fight going on I I
don't just like we keep coming back to
this awesome I was so like if this
episode is gonna be nothing but these
fucking watermelon I'm gonna be pissed
so you're not all for anything but
here's just an epic fight we've been
building up for quite a while and we
just keep coming back to these non
interesting watermelon to sacrifice
those anyway blocks of the Steven yes
that's kind of hard to identify with
them when they're just killing off their
own anyway um but uh okay
no I totally agree then once the actual
I turn to you when that fight started
I'm just like this very anime yeah well
I mean everything even it's shooting the
arrow and they see the three of them and
they come back into the ER I mean it was
some really cool toys yes Evangelion
kind of filled no I like to how like
when at first it forms it's like the
small eyes are on top and the big on the
bottom and then they close the eye and
they switch around almost like you can
see them fighting constantly a reception
edge that part of it was cool yeah and
thankfully in that that is a lot of it
which is good you know there is a lot of
fighting there is a lot of this this
battle they're building up that is
pretty cool I mean they've been building
a Malakai being trapped down there for a
while and getting stronger and bigger
and stuff and we got this fight and it
is a cool fight yeah I just wish there's
maybe a little bit more character
focused on like them like Steven and the
gems and even malachite and not as much
on the watermelons I just felt like oh
we could have been heavy more like
dialogue talks or psychological stuff or
something instead these water melon
melon heavy episode yes maybe melancholy
Oh
I'm totally flashing to better off dead
that's just what I do when people like
try to insult me I just do you reference
the only good John Cusack movie that
jockeys like doesn't like hi hey I liked
high fidelity but we're not here to talk
about junk you like movies uh we're at
I'm outside that's I think that's pretty
much it for that episode and I you know
the ending now that we know what happens
in the episode that follows it the
ending with them saying and ste you know
you can do it bro yeah you can do it and
Steven like we love you and stuff and
stops there it's like okay that's a good
cliffhanger like oh my god
good stuff really end here but I don't
know the next episode even though it's
good I feel like I mean there was
definitely a little bad that oh this
might be the end kind of thing but I I
don't know I didn't I didn't really feel
like it might be the end even though
it's like okay I know there's more
episodes I know you have a season and
stuff but it's like that dread wasn't
quite as heavy as it was in other
episodes
he's prattling on about I'm talking
about like cuz they're trying to build
up like what peridot and him are in
there and like the things crunching and
marriage she's like you know this might
be it Stephen D have any last words I
love you all things and stuff you know
there and even before then in that
episode when steam is fading away you
know they say you can do it bro you can
get the drill you know and then Darren
says and Steven we love you and it's
like wow so could this be like the last
that should be we're okay I see what
you're saying that should be where the
season should event I then ended there
it's like Steven we love you boom they
just never been like fun now wait for
the continuation but now that we know
the follow-up uh you know it's them
going down and it's fine it's a good
episode with gem drill but I felt like
man for that much of a build-up it's
like I never felt as much danger as I
have another epic a night I think we're
gonna have to accept that the way these
seasons are divided up is just arbitrary
and just fuck it
like don't don't think that way we're
just gonna have to take it as one giant
story and where it's divided up like
that cuz yeah I feel the same way I feel
why I feel like this could have been the
the the drill episode could have been a
season finale type it I just I think
we're just gonna have to get out of
there because who the wait Cartoon
Network was running this shit with
finally I was in timeout season finale I
was just saying like in general just
having that build up for what we got I
was kind of like I never felt that quite
that dread that this could be the final
like they come up do that's what I'm
saying it's because this is the
beginning of this season now so it's
just like well what the hell could hell
I say like I see what you're saying I'm
saying this would above this would have
worked better like okay if you had cut
off like the season right after the
watermelon episode I've gotten rid of
the watermelons yeah we went through
that if you had cut it there this would
have been way more interesting then you
open up with him getting the drill and
so you know they're not gonna die like
once you get them in the drill but I
mean it sets up that this is the
beginning of a new set I just wanted to
divide it with ice is how their um the
crazy television programming and if I
were running things so um so first of
all that's a fast two hours when she's
like you know it's actually two hours
until we get down there unless the break
was in there I mean maybe it was like
you got some tunes sure maybe they cut
their I think they cut it though we love
you line no I just I just assumed that
time ahead Sandman maybe um probably
what are you stupid little bit stupid um
I thought uh no it's uh I mean it really
good I like coming up will you shut up
um I like those shards all having a
personality the cluster I like the way
the cluster looked I like all the
various colors I like the shy like going
in it's very minimal but it's still very
a big sex education video I phases it
like the egg and like things are you
know never lovebirds coming out yeah
it felt very much like you know like I'm
like oh I'm back in fifth grade seeing
those primitive animations like actually
this would have been actually the sex ed
video is dumb like I'll let me more
attention full CGI baby um and Larry
you'll end up with a full CGI baby boss
crow must grow
um not I thought the representation was
cool I thought did yeah the yeah the
voices were creeping me out
I just lost grow Oh hard to make out
what they're saying to which I like
yeah I feel like what they say but I
kind of like you couldn't quite always
make it out cast even would translate am
i correct they don't want to grow though
that's what they said they said what not
L Stephen says I bet they don't want a
fuse they don't want to form they don't
want to do it but but they're still
can't do it like she said just because
they don't want to do it doesn't mean
they're not going to do it okay so they
don't want to but they can't stop either
I hope they delve into that a little
more because I wasn't quite following
I'm like why not well that's bubbled I
mean I'm sure they'll take like a break
or whatever but then they'll go back to
it cuz I'm a little treat by the to I
like PBS like cuz I just assumed they
would want to you know like it's like
they would cuz it's so many
consciousness and stuff it's like they
do when they don't which I kind of like
it's just like cuz it's not like before
were the fusions like two or three
people's I mean this is like bits and
pieces of tons of people so I like that
we don't wanna lose our individuality
but they're so they're trying to form
they're trying to make you know
something coherent but it's it's tricky
so I really like that idea at whatever
still makes more sense iniative
Evangelion less crayon to um but no I
thought was good i'm curious what
they're gonna do with um I don't least
once a loop is bopping at your name ah
lapis
yeah yfs I'm curious what they're gonna
do with it now go watch what house
recently it's not blue Oh
but yeah I'm curious what we're gonna do
with that character now that she's back
um and do they ever have a moment on
house where it was lupus I know they
really I if not I'm sure they really mr.
Abhi's yeah they should
Lisa at one push I had to be the foil
out the subway boys lupus at one point
it's like they go through everything
else at the end he's like no you idiots
it's lupus um but uh yeah no it's good
I'm curious where the you know the other
one the orange one that fell into the
crack she's still out there so you know
we can see what's gonna happen with that
she becomes the volcano God that they
worship that she does watermelon Island
she becomes the volcano and the next
times long a short before in SIA next
time Steven shows up there in that
island it's gonna be Steven versus the
volcano that's our way again for a
second um but uh ya know it's still good
episodes could use a little less
watermelon but you know like II do we
still got a really kick-ass fight and
someone's missing man so um yeah that's
about it we will see in the next episode
see you then